are you looking forward to the next time
Sony adds new features to the
PlayStation 4 well then you're in luck
because update 4.5 lands tomorrow and
I'm going to run you through everything
it adds I'm Matt this is a game spot
news update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to keep up on everything
PlayStation the 4.5 update adds boost
mode to the ps4 pro which aims to
improve the quality and performance of
games that haven't been patched to
support the more powerful console the
new feature can provide a boost to the
frame rate or stabilize it in games that
run at 30 or 60 frames per second it's
not guaranteed to work with every game
and can be turned off so they run as if
played on a standard ps4 the update also
makes 2d images look better inside a
virtual reality improves the resolution
of PlayStation VR cinematic mode and
adds voice chat to remote play on PC Mac
and Xperia devices and last but
definitely not least the 4.5 update adds
external hard drive support sony also
announced that it's bringing a small
handful of new features to its message
and community mobile apps you can check
those out on gamespot com but if you'd
rather focus on PlayStation games watch
our video about why horizon zero dawn
alloy is the best game protagonist in
years
you